every night for the last couple weeks
there's there's a barrage of fireworks
and it's really weird because it's like
gunfire
one of the people who works here on our
show lives in brooklyn
he just hung the microphone outside his
window this goes on
every night now listen to this this is
actual tape
and by the way it's not just new york
city and jersey it's even up in my
neighborhood in the suburbs
people are just fireworks crazy now i
don't know what the [ __ ] going on it's
like there's fireworks going off every
day in the street
what was richard telling us that he used
to do when he was a kid with fireworks i
used
to put him in my pants and
what did you do to the bus at school
what happened what was that all about
oh we put a big pack of black cats in
the uh
trash can bucket in the back of the bus
and it lit on fire and started a fire on
the bus
filled the bus with smoke and then the
bus driver ran off the road and we had
to evacuate the bus
tell the story that you blew a hole in
your living room floor and your parents
just moved the couch over it like they
didn't even
like yeah my dad
used to re fill shotgun shells so he had
a bunch of black powder around so
i took an empty toilet paper roll and
filled it with gunpowder
and then tried to drip wax on the top of
it to seal it and the flame
followed the wax down and the thing
exploded right in my hand
and blew a big hole in our uh floor
and our house filled up with smoke and
my mom comes and is like what the hell
is going on i said
oh i tried to make a firecracker and she
goes well put that chair over the hole
in the floor
please do not use fireworks and by the
way now's not a good time to go to the
hospital with your hand blown off
uh the hospitals they got bigger things
to worry about
happy fourth of july everybody
[Music]
absolutely